hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to destiny rebellion
we're gonna move on to another house
here whatever that may be
I think someone crying or is that a dog
what was that there's another optional
house called the entertainment house I
may not be getting a lot done with this
story but I am very eager to see what
other things is as in story for me okay
I'm going like a psycho great oh oh hi
hello you came here so you expect some
entertainment um yes indeed I do
my name is Finster if you want to start
a minigame just going one of your films
and talk to my colleagues let me go let
me go Finster Finster please I need to
go somewhere now go and play my game Wow
oh hi let me guess you're not gonna let
me out okay I'll play your game you will
drugs wow I am perfect so are all of you
[Music]
I'm not exactly sure what's going oh hi
hi okay this may not be as happy and
hunky-dory as I thought
Wacka monster Wookiee spider game let's
try mom how do i whack you Oh what is
happening what do we do oh I got a
crowbar oh yeah
okay I think that might have been German
talk but I'm not who I see you in their
bunk no oh no I get a I get hurry up
I've wasted enough time oh hello douche
I'm gonna getcha I'll getcha well well
well come on bring it on
bring on Wells's you anybody this is huh
what's going on hello see anyone else
sir no one else here something going on
here oh god you're splayed weird hello
friend what's going on I don't see
anybody is anybody else anybody want a
piece of me somebody want a piece of me
does anybody want a piece of me oh god
damn it where am I going what am i doing
who am i doing you two why did I get
them all
I have no idea someone in the toilet no
do not one hello what hello if you
wonder what hey I got blue wonder oh
that's for sanity on all these awards
mine I have no idea what's going on
[Music]
aardvark oh oh I get it
come on come on let me save my game ah
you won't let me find I don't need to
save my game right now time to try out
whatever other weird minigame that you
got for me whoa excuse me
I want that wall god what has happened
you don't know what's happening right
now what I love it I seriously have no
idea what's going on in this game at all
it says something like spider amnesia
follow the spiders there is no other
possibility anyway you screw you hard
okay hi feed her before she eats her
husband and her children am i her
husband of his work what do I do
oh wait no I picked it up I picked up to
me and there were things on the ceiling
over there but I don't really care about
that right now I picked up the meat
that's all I know here have my meat suck
it down well done it's beautiful all the
Flying Spaghetti Monster is noodley
appendage shell touches all frustrating
loud down a dumb quest I have to obtain
the loud down and dump he spells it
exactly like I say oh okay oh it's right
oh hey hey come back here you [ __ ] hey
where'd you go
okay I'm coming for you hey you douche
ah you son of a [ __ ] you think you can
get away from me but I am Marga buyer
and nobody can escape me not even law
down to them
where'd you
wait a minute how do I get to you how do
I get to wear it all I just picked up
the peg why why did I just pick up the
pig
oh hello I think I need you do I need
you I got you so I'm assuming that I
need you how the hell do I do
oh come on he's right there now how do I
get to there what do I need to do like
bring your ass why do I have a pig
Oh need pig fat to get through the bars
ah I get it I need to lubricate myself
before I'm able to go through oh wait
are you
oh wait pig fat is explosive boy I don't
get it but I'm coming for you [ __ ] you
come back here you low down in the
bastard
okay brown picked up the watch the
monster will come kill me quickly that
monster
[Music]
Oh forgot to tell me something what
monsters gonna come back and get me
anyway I knew it was a trick it was a
trick I'm gonna go get the lowdown Adam
come here you [ __ ]
I'm coming for you baby where'd you go
whoa thank you
give the law down in them to the
hippopotamus what if I eat it myself
wait the most unusual thing in all of
them needs you well if I give it to one
of these statue deuces no okay if you
say so okay I'm having too much fun I'm
having literally too much fun playing
this I cannot stop having fun playing
this okay I think there was another one
over here I'm not exactly sure I think
there might have been another one on the
other side of feetball Wow okay I I've
been touched by its nuclear blendin's ow
Oh football non americano
oh that's Wow you didn't even died for
it you douche come on come on I want to
see what you got
oh not that one maybe cuz I'm throwing
it it's a little unfair Oh God honestly
you actually block come on Wow Wow why
did that hurt I have no idea okay
there's only one more path that I can go
I think wow you're still blocking my
exit I still can't save apparently what
the hell
oh my god it's totally flat that's
awesome I'm hurting but I heard that
before hi you ever wonder why they put
in two hot dogs his protest against
genetic okay
whoa whoa wait a minute let's back up a
few steps you back up on the LSD trip
over here ow
let's get the piss out of me you say hi
Hey
oh you're moving and I can still pick
you up you're not moving though oh yeah
oh you're gonna come with me oh I shall
call you mini grunt and you shall be my
buddy here dive into this spit on him
whoa I didn't even notice that
[Music]
give me that is twitchy and weird okay
exterminator okay so what do I do
kill these little bastards ah you son of
a [ __ ] I'll kill ya right okay so I
need to kill these delightful rats no
I'm guessing that's cheese that you're
trying to eat over there and those are
the more dead rats okay so what am i
doing what am i doing some under the
stairs is never anything under the
stairs so what do I do
what do you want me to do oh hi hi
you're a little creepy please help you
with this okay if you I can't look away
with you just try throwing some
chemicals down there and exterminate the
villain vermin and save the cheese okay
how about this one how risky did I kill
him no not yet they need more all right
shadows key that didn't do anything
damn it how about this one
yeah I didn't do anything it didn't
break
this is totally useless why I would go
that broke well they're not dying it's
also point all this what's the point
oh I didn't break about this one I don't
even think this is chemical did I do it
right did I do it wrong what did I do
[Music]
I think I don't know what that was about
that wasn't as fun as the other ones
okay drop down let's go this one last
game that I can do one last game very
you to give it a try quiz game oh okay
are you did you ever think I could take
you with me I would my age oh oh here we
go wait a minute that's an awfully big
range here you're not young but age
brings you women wisdom and experience I
am a strong independent man but only a
woman I thought so at least you're
honest
or trying to be honest okay
what aspect of amnesia custom toys are
most important to you fun and
entertainment unique above all else it
has to be unique Bravo okay what do I
hate all you you son of a [ __ ] you evil
bastard okay you've chosen the suitor to
be honest these guys are disturbing even
for creatures who used to could see them
every day your favorite andis character
ah no no no I love Justine Justine is
such an interesting character I really
like it oh okay my opinion disgusting
gross overused definitely not
okay intrical part some kids are quite
exciting unlike any other exactly how I
would describe it how I hit myself why
I'm an idiot okay cool I'm an idiot
I think I'm done oh man that was so cool
I loved every part of that bye you're
never too old to have some entertainment
right I love it oh my god that was so
cool oh my face hurts from smiling so
much alright anyway so if you're eager
for me to get into the story of this
game don't worry is coming next I won't
do another optional one for a while if I
see another optional house I'm gonna go
past it but that was awesome you have to
admit that was pretty awesome especially
for being made in amnesia that was
awesome
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching let me know what you think of
the custom story in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video pretty much none of these are good
ways to die but that one especially
I mean for one they're chopping right
through your knives so that's doubly I
mean that's that's an equal
opportunities bad that's bad for both
women and men